[Music]
well that girl in Schindler's List
really grew up she shivers in the wind
like the last leaf on a dying tree he
narrates in the scene like the last rule
in a dying film career this title is so
amazing it requires a trademark also
this is definitely our kind of movie
which means let's add a sin for no
reason
Wow Brittany Murphy Michael Clarke
Duncan has anyone examined the
possibility that starring in this movie
is hazardous to your health
Michael Madsen still alive right
somewhere there's a murder victim who
could claim the same thing probably from
some other Robert Rodriguez just one
hour to go my last day on the job
someone recorded Bruce Willis saying
this in his dressing room and it made
the final cut in that backup that we're
waiting on well just so happen to show
up just late enough for Roark to get
back to his US Senator daddy I can't
tell if this is exposition I need to
know or exposition I can ignore so I'm
just gonna go with ignore for now you're
pushing 60 and you got a bum ticker this
guy looks pretty amazing for pushing 60
especially since the actor playing him
was 50 we're all done here many would be
in a minute Lenny these twin brothers
have to remind themselves of their
rhyming names when they talk to each
other doctor said it'd be like this just
take the pill he gave you must narrate
everything must resist urge to let
visuals speak for themselves cop with
angina bust through the door like it's
made of paper and I'd like to remind
everyone that he would have had to build
up some amazing momentum running up the
stairs to break a door like this oh okay
then
goodbye physics we'll see you after the
film oh dude you have a kidnapped child
in your arms watch your mouth cartoon
blood doesn't offend the nancy's at the
MPAA dick shot already about the dye guy
gets shot a bunch of times but because
it's Bruce Willis you already know he's
gonna survive this so what's the fucking
point give his mind off the girl skinny
romance
Hartigan narrates everything including
the weight of the kidnap victim the
night is hot as hell there's narration
and then there's Sin City she smells
like angels on a smell holy the perfect
woman
Ripley with Elijah Wood in this movie
and Bruce Willis narrating everything I
swear I'm watching a twisted sequel to
North corpse nudity I realize all these
dead you'd have to check her pulse
notice those perfect breasts of hers
moving like they would if she was
breathing okay so when do I need to stop
watching the breasts because I don't
have a natural timer that goes off in my
head concerning such things no reason at
all that's exactly what hardigan said a
minute ago this is the narrator unions
Creed ah nice and soft garbage bags
nothing hard or jagged is ever in one of
those you'd probably have to check this
woman's perfect breasts to make sure
she's not dead you know if you're gonna
make a character who can survive this
then there's really no reason he should
even be running from the cops discount
will help Weiner up the Sin City movie
to bring you one of the underwater Mario
levels carla Gugino his breasts are
probably worth removing a sin form
oh hell maybe - carla Gugino s breasts
while holding a gun that's probably
worth another couple subtractions carla
Gugino yeah you know what this movie's
trying to distract me from a job
intruder in your house get some clothes
on already she's a dyke the godly life
dude dyke is not the preferred
nomenclature leve american please what
the hell is this asshole jumping off a
building for well I'm gonna fund that
son of a bitch that killed you chase
we've already been through this
oh so it's one of those pg-13 strip
clubs wait let me check the box real
quick
this movie's rated R why am I in a pg-13
strip club when the movies rated R also
stripper character does not perform a
lap dance Brittany Murphy is dead
most people sing more of his crazy oh
really it would be possible for us to
hear what most people in the bar are
thinking right now - as Marv looked like
the kind of guy who can easily be taken
by two guys amateurs and would have been
insane I'm sorry well constant narration
is the big one
I don't know how many Hail Marys and our
fathers you have to do to cleanse
yourself of that but hopefully we don't
hear you narrating them
this guy survives getting run over three
times
who does Marvin think he is Stephen King
and she drives away for no reason even
though he's still alive and she's got
revenge on her mind roll credits Marv is
dead blue would go via carla Gugino his
legs would be a sin in this movie but
her legs are awesome too there's not
much of naked carla Gugino can do to
make any situation worse eats people so
why are you still here did he get full
did he know to save you for last because
you and Marv actually know each other
and that Marv was gonna break onto the
farm isn't Sin City a huge city discount
evil Charlie Brown's shirt I didn't know
she was a hooker how could this guy of
all people not be able to tell a hooker
from a non hooker he's done nothing this
whole movie would brag about his street
smarts and keen senses damn lucky that
Kevin has a friend who doesn't mind
driving his limo out to the farm or else
Marv doesn't get a chance to do this
possible doesn't check in the house come
this way
didn't they see Marv and Lucille when
they landed the helicopter also why are
they still here looking at the house why
didn't they get the hell out of here
already blowing away carla Gugino is
definitely a sin guys with guns decide
to ignore guns and attempt to take mark
down by hand and one of the time to boot
guy with gun finally decides to shoot
and of course he hits one of the few
cops still left standing after the fist
fighting then he runs out of bullets at
just the right time this town should be
called convenient city hooker statue on
statue violence
where's Goldie and by God I will remove
your hat if I have to
Wendy shows up out of nowhere to try and
complete a job she drove away from for
no reason a few minutes ago this guy is
the Energizer Bunny of not being
killable Goldie was my sister my twin
sister
I tied those nuts that's my specialty
oh I see all the girls have specialties
and mentioned them frequently in
conversation with people who surely know
about them already
magic hatchet and gun are readily
available on tables in a room with no
tables symmetrical standing call do work
declare change just like that a whopper
of a puzzle piece falls smack in
I'm too dumb to put the whole picture
together seriously this is like putting
together one of those 500 piece puzzles
and only have missing this like a couple
corner pieces but even though you see
the lighthouse and the boat in the
picture the two missing pieces of water
and grass are making you down it's a
lighthouse at a boat slick right after
Marv says this Kevin jump kicks a
hanging trenchcoat expecting that to be
a person Marv removes his handcuffs from
psycho assassin in order to put Wendy in
the car that guy could wake up at any
time but sure let's go all the way back
to the car to make sure unconscious
Wendy doesn't see any violence man I
went to wood took the method acting way
too far to become Frodo
it really gets my guys rough up Dame's
oh yeah so going after Roarke means
dying come on you can't die Marv more
than three-quarters of your body is made
of car parts bullets and tragedy they
should have shot me in the head yeah
sure the head like that was gonna work
all this happened on New Year's Eve once
no one's celebrating the New Year last
night also this article by one F Miller
is the script of the movie no one would
buy this newspaper because they'd be
confused as to what the hell he's
talking about
Plus this newspaper that is reporting
the Cardinals murder by way of the Sin
City script completely removed the Bruce
Willis part from its story in comedy cop
does that mean Marv gets to be Wendy
because I'd pay double price for that
Sin City lets people visit prisoners
right inside their private cells prisons
holding death row murderers allow
sleepovers he's gone
stethoscope obviously lies to the doctor
[Music]
that's racist
can i watch who is he yes
DC Comics I have never in my life writer
with obvious woman beating fetish keeps
populating his script with dialogue
insisting he dislikes violence against
women she said keep your hands to
yourself movie steals dialogue from my
everyday interactions with trader Drew's
checkout girl peripheral vision is for
suckers wiener up the Sin City movie to
bring you Trainspotting I'll call you
later and then Dwight jumps from the
ledge for no reason him he just jumped
off that terribly high window and landed
safely in the grass because this movie
doesn't give a fuck about establishing
internal rules let alone sticking to
them the cop shuts off his siren you
know she's not the law the ladies are
the law here this makes for a cool movie
gang of chicks but I think everyone
knows that hookers aren't capable of
taking over a single transaction let
alone an entire section of a city the
light
I saw the law here unless Marvin's here
shaking them down for answers about
Goldie besides I don't do good jobs and
Rory Gilmore turned into a total hooker
after the fifth season I don't jobs
either it's really tough to find good
talk jobs you got to be able to find
someone who's a ventriloquist to get it
right that's far enough
movie goes to great lengths earlier to
explain that Wayne has a new face but
this chick recognizes him instantly
anyway tatula Nova's little mayyyyyo
that means my whoring racist american
dialect mijo sticks the swords into the
top of the car but it takes another
second or two for them to show up in the
next shot just because your swastika is
a throwing star doesn't mean it's not
still a swastika Fisher block the barrel
is a backfire I told you to shut up
it's not like it's difficult to see the
Chi pelant the barrel and since we find
out that this due to the cop it really
is dummy doesn't notice iron jack the
papers call him a goddamn hero cop a
criminal this savvy doesn't know what
the iron jack he broke out from the
newspapers looked like he a movie I
thought Charlie said stop
she said Cobb seems like this would have
been something Shelley would have said
we earlier like before Jackie boy got
into the apartment you know when Dwight
told her that he'd take care of him and
all of that but no she waited until he
was jumping off a ledge to try and tell
him did you forget that cop car that
trailed him here
the cops know Rafferty came here and yet
they were chasing him like a common
criminal like they didn't know who he
was
also if Rafferty was a cop why didn't he
just pull over when the cops were
chasing him he's a hero cop so he's
definitely not undercover or anything
like that because his face is too
recognizable and even if the cops aren't
as corrupt as we've been led to believe
they wouldn't have arrested him anyway
the surprise revelation makes pretty
much no sense
carpet sheriff that guys have no
peripheral vision and never look in any
direction so the Dwight can just hide in
plain view there is absolutely no reason
why these guys need to stay here Blake
thinks way down into the tower but Miho
not only knows exactly where to look for
him in the not see through thar she also
manages to swim down to him and drag him
back up without either of them drowning
at least 10 minutes behind and probably
more this magic country road leads
perfectly to the exact spot where the
mercenaries are driving so that this
crash can happen any noise I'll be doing
you with fan guy switches from grenades
to a knife because when it's personal
stupidity wins
you couldn't never offer me so just on
the off chance that some cop comes
wandering into old town and that cop
dies you played informant given the
truce involved when did you ever think
that was gonna happen it's a
million-to-one shot it's like telling
someone if you ever win the lottery I'll
let you keep 30 grand
it isn't right there wasn't no tape over
his mouth jeez what an observant little
whore
how many IVs does this asshole need
eight years pass which means you're now
about 68 but you still look 50 or 45 or
whatever Bruce Willis looks like how the
hell did they find her she was so
careful she never gave away where she
lives regressions work well for starters
she was the only person writing you
letters for the last eight years you
have no friends
but everyone remembers a little girl
coming to visit you in the hospital I
don't know man seems like you should be
thankful it took them this long to find
her considering how easy it should have
been I agree to everything they want for
me I love you Nancy so the dirty raping
child molesting confessor is upon his
confession immediately released from
prison for what time served even in a
story completely devoid of physics and
common sense this makes no sense
longtime veteran a police force doesn't
notice this car or they obviously yellow
dude in it she got remarried four years
ago she had two kids
damn how old was his wife if he was
pushing 60 was he married to someone in
her 20s or early 30s it's possible I
guess but not likely how did they find
out who you are dude how the fuck do you
know where she lives either she's living
in a publicly listed address or she put
her new address in the letters either
way how the fuck did the yellow man not
find her in the last eight years don't
notice me don't recognize me don't look
at her you need to get out right this
second you have more than enough clothes
on in this pg13 strip club what is it
about right this second that wasn't
clear to you besides from the sound of
things I might have to shoot somebody
Nancy waited until they had driven miles
down the road to finish this thought
damn the rooks are so special they buy
cars with the driver's seat on the right
side also why did he wait until now to
start blasting why wasn't he waiting for
them when they got to the car it's not
like they didn't take their time before
we're leaving the bar the steak
I almost gag better take a closer smell
then dumbass
somehow it stays with us all the way to
the motel because the movie villain is
in your back seat or trunk damn Hartigan
I just pointed this possibility out
giant ass motel room is giant ass we've
already discussed the smell thing but
wouldn't there have been bright yellow
blood tracks all the way to Nancy's car
that would have ended this plan pretty
quickly also even if he somehow totally
found a way to hide his bright yellow
injured self while hardigan investigated
the crash then found a way into the back
seat a Nancy's car why didn't he just
kill them on the way there also how did
they not ever notice the bright yellow
bastard in the back seat of the car even
if there was no blood around wait I
forgot you were Jessica Alba No
siring he's totally fucking her saving
her as a little kid would not in any way
impact the power of boners and then you
add in the fact that growing up her is
Jessica Alba you movie is wrong in
they're stronger than their sis wrong we
all wanted who wrote all those letters
she left not a clue well you knew who
wrote the letters right you know what
had to be Nancy right
you just didn't know where she was for
some reason we just don't scream says
the guy who's never been raped and cut
up into pieces bad guy leaves before
insuring the only guy who can stop him
is actually dead cliche because you can
totally grab a convenient large shard of
glass with your feet after breaking a
window and with your toes pointed the
other way
we're in are we to repository cently
deceased cargo you waited until you got
to the dead body to point out that the
vehicle you're in is useless for the job
oh look kevin is here he will spend no
time helping out in any way during this
entire fight for some reason even though
he's a horrible cannibal psycho bastard
who loves killing also this may be
beside the point but exactly how many
evil creepy rapists cannibal killers
were living on this farm at the same
time did they never have arguments over
any of the captives I get to see your
eyes well I fillet the woman of your
dreams right in front of you why I
didn't do this before is immaterial the
plot of the movie wouldn't allow it
that's the same thing he said to him
eight years ago hey movie repetition
does not equal symbolism I'm taking no
chances with you but you just took a
humongous chance by letting Nancy go you
moron here it comes
it's gonna hurt to it already movie ends
but then sadly like most of its
characters comes back to life
oh yeah yo scream you bitch battles a
cow
[Music]
you can't even lift again and you Jerry
it's conceivable you miserable vomitus
mess where's the money Lebowski it's
people have you been eavesdropping hi
ever dropping no eaves sir honest when
you recorded them
you demon you're an errand boy sent by
grocery looks okay where's it be caught
he wanted me to lock him up and he
answer you
[Music]
this is the end unstable times for man
in your position to volunteer realistic
I hope you were the groom Ted Nugent
called he wants his shirt back good
advice
after a while all I'm doing is bounding
wet chuckles phone into the floorboards
so I stopped you up strong